Apple just announced the M2 Mac Minis
and some of these are the best value
computers in the world but with that
some are actually a terrible value now
there are so many different
configurations and options to choose
from being able to upgrade your CPU your
graphics your storage and your RAM so
I'm gonna help you guys out so you guys
don't make some major mistakes when you
are purchasing one and with that once
you start specking it up you get close
to the price and even exceed the price
of some of the Mac Studio so we'll also
talk about who should buy a new Mac Mini
and who should just get a Mac Studio
potentially at a discounted price now
before I jump in I have to let you know
that we are giving away a Mac Mini and a
new Macbook Pro and all you have to do
is be subscribed to channel enable
notifications and leave a comment on
these videos during the launch week the
more you watch and comment the better
your chances and we are going to reveal
the winner on February 1st so make sure
you guys don't miss out on that now
looking at this configuration right here
we have three different choices from
Apple the base one actually dropped by a
hundred dollars compared to the M1 which
really shocked us but not only that if
you're gonna buy for educational prices
you can get one for 499
which is absolutely insane now taking a
look at the base model here it comes
with the M2 Chip and the killer thing is
that it comes with a full a core CPU and
a 10 core GPU compared to the 1200 M2
MacBook Air where you actually have a
weaker Bend Graphics in there that has
eight cores and then you actually have
to pay another hundred dollars thirteen
hundred total to get the full
performance where here you get all of
that now that does not mean that it is
without its issues because for the base
storage the 256 gig SSD I presume that
just like the M2 MacBook Air and M2
MacBook Pro it has just one nand storage
chip which means that the performance is
going to be half that compared to even
the M1 Mac Mini and that does affect
real world as well so if you're doing
some productivity and some web browsing
you can get some very major slowdowns so
I would say even if you're buying a base
model your budget's not very high go
ahead and upgrade to the 512 gigabyte
SSD because you don't only get double
the storage but you also get much faster
storage and with these machines if you
have eight gigs of memory well you're
going to use the SSD as RAM and that's
going to make your machine much nappier
and that will make your SSD last at
least twice as long roughly 10 years
compared to four or five which is a big
deal and that is why Apple for their
mitts stack model the only difference is
that it comes with 512 gigabytes of SSD
now we also have some differences
between the M2 Chip and the M2 Pro
Models now as you guys can see the price
tag goes up significantly now a portion
of that is because it also comes with 16
gigabytes of RAM so if we go into this
mid-spec one and we jump up to 16 gigs
it gives us two thousand dollars so
we're going to talk about who should
spend the extra money to get that M2
Chip but one difference other than that
chip is the fact that the higher end M2
pro model has four Thunderbolt ports
instead of two now that is very
convenient we have been using the M1 Mac
Mini for a while and it definitely is
limiting having just two of those USB
type-c ports you use it for storage use
it for displays and that is nice to have
now you can get a dock like like the OWC
now the next mistake you can make is
limiting your display connectivity the
M2 Chip Mac minis have the same
capability as the M1 so you could do a
6K display up to 60 hertz over
Thunderbolt or if you're using the HDMI
uh then you can use 4K 60. now with the
M2 Pro chips you have much more power
not only can you connect up to three
displays two being 6K and then a 4K over
HDMI but if you use two one of those
could be 4K
144 Hertz which is great to have or if
you only want one it is future proof
because it could support 8K at 60 hertz
or even 4K at 240 hertz this is a new
standard that is just hitting the market
right now with these the Max and the
last physical difference is that the M2
pro model actually weighs more than the
one with the regular M2 and I presume
that is because as it has a better
cooling system to handle a lot more
power and with that it actually has a
slightly more powerful power supply
built into the machine and that means
even when you're doing Simple tasks it
should run a little bit cooler or have
the fan be able to run slower getting
back to the configurator if you're
wondering if you should upgrade your SSD
past 512 I would say don't make this
mistake now while it is nice to have it
built in you are spending two hundred
dollars to get an extra 500 gigs of SSD
now personally we love our saber rocket
ssds I use mine all the time and for 220
you get a full one terabyte that is
incredibly fast over Thunderbolts it
could also be backwards compatible with
USBC if you can plug it into a Mac so
you can use it with a lot of computers
not just the Mac Mini and it costs you
practically the same amount now the same
thing goes if you want to go up to two
terabyte that is a 600 upgrade that's
locked into your Mac compared to
spending three hundred and sixty dollars
for two terabytes that you can always
keep with you so I'll leave a link to
those down below now getting into RAM
the second upgrade I would do other than
going to 512 would be to jump to 16 gigs
of unified memory doing both at SSD and
that memory with this M2 Chip gave us
great performance in a lot of
applications for example if you do photo
editing it definitely speeds that up and
it helps across the board and the M2
Chip screams with 16 gigs of memory now
here you can go all the way up to 24
gigabytes the M2 Pro can actually go
higher but in our testing with the M2
MacBook gear and MacBook Pros for most
applications because of the fast swap
you don't really need to so unless you
have unlimited budget I would say 16
gigs is a sweet spot even for
productivity now the next stake is the
ethernet port I bought my Mac Mini
before we had this 10 gigabit Ethernet
option and now I have to get rid of it
to get a whole new one because you can't
upgrade it now it's an extra 100 bucks
and that makes ethernet port 10 times
faster nowadays most people use Wi-Fi
and so not everybody needs it but if
you're gonna connect to a server or to a
switch and you got to think about two
three years from now that is money well
spent but with that all of these new M2
Mac minis actually come with Wi-Fi 6E
and Bluetooth 5.3 so not even the M2
MacBook airs have this and that means
that if you upgrade your Wi-Fi router
you might not even need to have that
ethernet port the new routers are really
fast so if you don't think you're gonna
use it don't make the mistake by
spending that extra hundred bucks now I
think this 999 dollar configuration is
going to be excellent for a lot of
people even for 4K video editing prores
because it has that decode as an
encoders photo editing it's gonna scream
compared to your previous Mac or Windows
computer but with that for 300 more you
can upgrade to that M2 Pro that has four
Thunderbolt ports that has the better
cooler included and that has all the
support for the external displays now at
the base here you actually do not get
the full M2 Pro chip your CPUs bin so
you have six performance cores instead
of eight giving you a total of ten and
the graphics has actually been as well
16 to 19. now if we go and we take a
look at the performance of the M2 Pro
compared to the M2 you will see that
depending on what you're doing the gains
don't seem like they're massively
improved for example people the neural
engine is the same in both models for
video editing it is quite a bit faster
because of the extra graphics
performance and in productivity the
difference is very very minimal so you
have to think about what you're going to
do now with that said we actually
ordered three Mac minis because we are
going to test out the difference
depending on what real world tasks you
are doing so here for video editing they
show that we have pretty much double the
scaling because I have extra graphics
and for transcoding it's not double but
you do have an improvement we're going
to do much more tests so make sure
you're subscribed and you have those
notifications enabled now one thing that
they don't show you on this chart so you
have to make sure that you don't make
this mistake is that when you're looking
here they're not comparing the base
models and they're not comparing that
bend version that comes in at thirteen
hundred dollars those performance
differences even though sometimes
they're not that big that goes off of
the full on sixteen hundred dollar model
and also with the ram kicked up even
higher so I think for a lot of people
you don't need to upgrade to the M2 Pro
unless you know you need that absolute
best performance now if you're wondering
about upgrading 232 gigs of RAM well go
ahead and check out my video comparing
16 gigs to 32 with the M1 Pro and how
well the 16 gig version works it works a
lot better than you expected and I think
it's going to be very similar for this
machine so don't make the mistake of
upgrading your RAM unless you absolutely
know that you need to and that video
will help now the next mistake a major
one that you can make is to spend two
grand on an Mt Pro Mac Mini when for the
same price you can ask actually get a
Mac Studio but with that said some of
you guys actually Should Skip on the Mac
Studio and go for the M2 Pro so I'll
help you guys decide now as I showed you
you can actually pick one up for
eighteen hundred dollars that's actually
cheaper than the M2 Pro Mac Mini and it
actually comes with a 10 gigabit
Ethernet port which brings you up to
2100 for that Mac Mini now for those of
you guys that do Graphics related tasks
for example rendering in blender even
doing photo or video editing that use
the GPU this thing actually has a 24
core GPU at base or for 200 bucks you
can actually upgrade to 32 core which is
what we personally use here at Max Tech
and that is a lot of performance more
graphics performance than the M2 Pro now
on the flip side if you use cpu-based
tasks for example if you do a lot of
photo editing with Lightroom well this
thing actually has a worse CPU you then
that Mac Mini which will have about 20
percent better CPU performance now don't
worry we're gonna do a comparison
between a high-end M2 Pro Mac mini
versus the Mac Studio to help you guys
decide based on what you guys do and I'm
very excited for that now other than the
chip the M1 Max that is in here the Mac
Studio comes with an SD card slot which
we absolutely love that it has that it
also has two USB type A's but with the
four Thunderbolt ports for the base
models you also get two USB type-c ports
which are really nice to have and when
we tore this thing apart it has such a
beefy cooler so it's silent no matter
what you throw at it so for a lot of
people the Mac Studio is going to make a
lot more sense but the one downside is
the HDMI port that is built into it only
supports 4K 60 over the HDMI and then 6K
60 over the Thunderbolt Port so the Mac
Mini is more future proof along with
having Wi-Fi 6E and the latest Bluetooth
as well but overall I have three
configurations that I recommend the very
base model if you only do web browsing
and you're not a tight budget I would go
at least up to 512 or 16 gigs as well to
have a very well-rounded machine and if
you want the extra ports and the
connectivity go up to that thirteen
hundred dollars but I would say stay
away from the higher end prices because
you start clashing with that Mac Studio
so make sure you guys are subscribed and
you comment down below enable
notifications if you want a chance to
win a Mac Mini or a MacBook Pro that
will be given away on February 1st uh go
ahead and check out the YouTube shopping
feature if you want to pick up one of
these machines check out one of those
videos right over there and we'll see
you in the next one
[Music]
thank you